so you like to butter the customers I
like to butter the customers because I
want my customers to come back happy and
satisfied so you actually take products
a pride I say your honor everything I do
she was there for a year hi my name's
Nick sir and I work at Subway for a
whopping week hi my name is Mason luck
and I worked at Subway for two months
hi I'm Theresa aka freedom and I worked
at Subway for about a year
hi my name is Jonathan David Manor and I
worked at Subway for about six months
and today we're going to play never have
I ever
subway edition never have I ever messed
up an order but served it anyway I
didn't know what I was doing a lot of
the times like we're not working at
Subway if you just get like close to the
same tastes like kind of in the ballpark
of what people want it they'll never
know anyway so you might as well just
serve it I'm gonna say no because I was
such a perfectionist cuz it was my first
job so I wanted everything to be pretty
accurate but I'm gonna say no I mean
maybe I did but I don't think so not
that you know of
that's my Noah psych all my sandwiches
was perfect never have I ever not said
welcome to subway when someone enters
the door I got a whole bunch of
customers deferment I'm helping people
with sandwiches I think you are the
least of my worries and I shouldn't have
to say welcome to Subway I mean I
managed to get honest a lot of times
about that but I mean I did an
inner-tube a he while she's gonna serve
just like everybody else oh I never
agreed at anyone yeah your perfectionist
and with making the sandwich not with
not with socialization look see I might
not like necessarily say hi when you
walk in but when I make that eye contact
with you and I gaze into your eyes
thanks what kind of sandwich would you
like of course I'm gonna say hi how you
doing
never have I ever gotten fed up with a
customer that didn't make up their mind
what's he gonna do know you a sister go
ahead there you go I'm just gonna hold
this up the entire time yeah I'm gonna
get frustrated different combinations
well on the contrary I think that
kindness
three and a lot of times people don't
know what they want and unless you tell
them and that's how people are sometimes
you just have to know human nature now
people are like I want olives no I don't
really well actually yeah like extra
olives like what do you want ma'am six
olives I've scrapped entire sandwiches
because people change their mind halfway
through and I'm just like never have I
ever been yelled at by customers I have
been yields by to yelled at by two
customers I don't know but how dare you
have the audacity so coming to a
fast-food restaurant and want to yell at
somebody I don't think I was there long
enough to get yelled at if people would
have known how bad I messed up their
sandwiches they may yell at me
people get very angry over food which I
understand hangry miss but like it's a
Subway sandwich you don't need to pop
off that bad never have I ever kept
expired produce on the production line
Wow really
I was busy hey just because the
expiration date says you're not supposed
to put it out there don't you had them
I'm pretty sure you had a mom when you
had leftovers she'd be like oh here neat
that it now you know I ain't that bad
they brought sometimes you know you're
trying to save the company some money I
would not serve people expired food this
guy probably would I mean it was
probably like about the same I will
never give anyone purposely salmonella
damn I can't say it right or eco life
eco life that is wrong never have I ever
given friends family or crushes free
subs surprising I know I was there
Michael Syria ain't knows it
that's what that's like a confessions
brightest I mean they can't hurt us now
it was my parents they came in they were
so proud of me and they're like oh my
god it's your first job I just thought
it would be cute to make them free
sandwiches no I can't see girls I was 16
I was young and I never got arrested
people used to like families used to
come in and they used to be like oh yeah
can we get like three fold food laws so
what I used to do loads I string good
like one or two footlongs and then
pocket the rest of the money
cuz they had me six years old working by
myself that's the real reason why
because I was promised I used to rob
they say have no cameras in there oh yes
I did it I did it I do too I did I do
I was in a new city so I had no friends
no family there if there was a crush God
helped me if they saw me there never
have I ever eaten a sub that was made by
mistake thrown out I don't think so yeah
if it's made wrong it goes in the trash
it's like if it's the sandwich I was
gonna make anyways why not keep it
come on I don't know so you didn't
purposely make this up by mistake you
didn't by mistake like it's kind of hard
to mess up a subway sandwich when they
making it right in front of your face
actually I disagree because a lot of
times were you making a Subway sandwich
I mean for some reason Mayo sounded like
mustard and right when you put a line of
mustard on there they like nope I'm not
even listening problems
I never messed up I'm a man never have I
ever added extra ingredients without
charging you already know of course I
used to steal from Subway yeah you go I
did not care it wasn't coming out of my
paycheck or my pockets and I liked
seeing people happy every managers
nightmare
I used to do it all the time Thanks
taste look over me excuse me Jonathan
okay can you please just go by the
portion like just once you pick it up
and just don't level it off or Pat it
down just kind of like shake it off like
no bro like this people this man paid
$10 for this sandwich I'm gonna give him
some weight I would do a lot of extra
veggies and stuff but I would never do
extra meat apparently and that's why I
got yelled up yeah I use those people
live you know why not bro
why not sorry subway I'm not sorry why
not you know never have I ever gotten
injured at work I have to if I would
have gotten injured within the first
week that I was there I shouldn't have
been there in the first place so no I
did not yeah oh man I got burned by the
toaster oven
cutting things can get pretty dicey but
no I've never injured myself at Subway
so I just forget the subway right by my
high school then a chance for me to the
subway at Walmart and so at the end of
the night I used to have to pick up the
trash I could
stuff a few times throwing away garbage
though they transfer you because they
find out that you still there never have
I ever seen a co-worker do something
they would get fired for people I was
that co-worker we have a no snitch
policy you know among Subway co-workers
no I don't know about yours but we don't
snitch on each other because if he
making his sandwich I'm gonna make my
sandwich people would make so many
sandwiches and just walk out with them
and then oh well then I was that
employee my coworker was there for five
years so she was there for a reason
because she was doing her job right so I
guess I was the one managers her baby
daddy had got out of the jail and then
he came the subway and they went to the
bathroom and they did some things they
wasn't supposed to do so yeah I slept I
was a little ratchet that's a kindness
is free just be kind of me and I be kind
of you and I'll remember that I'm making
a sandwich go ahead you know subway
go be fresh
[Music]